just pearly things what do you think I
want to think about what about her
getting in trouble
it was bound to happen okay if you
aren't aware there's pearly things the
lady
who's 26 uh unmarried single career
driven and constantly tries to educate
women on how to be submissive and
married by 25
um it's gotten in trouble recently not
for not taking her own advice and being
the opposite of whatever the [__] she
preaches but more so uh for having Nick
Fuentes who's a uh white supremacist
anti-semite
um on her platform and basically when
she invited him on the platform for an
interview she didn't push back against
any of the stuff that she said basically
was co-signing him I and I just like to
say when you come on pearly things yeah
all right we've got back
down and you and you've ate off just
pearly things by tagging us yeah and
your production is not our production
our production is Big out here you get
me I got bear smoke for you look bro
both of you look I got smoke for Abba
and preach bro he's been saying [__] now
right though you ain't saying [__] now
yeah yeah if you if you come in because
[Music]
yeah yeah and what about when people
come from one of y'all
what's she gonna do
nothing listen I'll say this about Pro
[__] out of here clown I think it's wild
that people have an issue with her right
now when she's made her entire career on
clowning black women yeah it's like oh
now that she said something about black
people as a whole y'all got an issue but
when she was clowning but I remember
this girl used to have videos back in
the day she used to hit me up all the
time I never really responded much she
used to hit us up and she's like oh I
want to interview you guys you know I
got one of the girl fastest growing
podcasts in the world this is like when
she had like 100k subs and she had this
video it's like look at this video is
going viral and it was her talking to
this black woman telling her how
ridiculous she is and on the face of it
it's like all right whatever it's fine
but when I started seeing her try to do
the new come up where she transitioned
from what she used to be which was
before her videos were like whitest girl
in the world reacts to new rap song why
this girl in the world reacts to Abba
and preach why does I'm like okay this
is racial Dynamic that she keeps playing
into this corny and cringe as [__] but
she saw it as a marketing point that was
her in to get in right she then
transitioned to The Next Step which is
like oh I see what Kevin Samuels and
some of these other red pills were doing
let me try to emulate that so she
inserted herself and she was just
talking and I was like y'all don't find
it [__] weird
that a white woman who grew up in a
extremely wealthy in some rural part of
America okay
so I'm gonna show you the friend of the
house so I wish I could like be in these
videos but I could not find a sibling
that felt like
he's making her career giving marriage
and life advice as some young 22 23 year
old to older black women I'm like you
ain't got any Asian eight Latinos white
women no black one so I was already
looking at her a little bit weird and I
never she invited me a bunch of times I
never wanted to go on my today's sponsor
t.h Henley's coming in to save the day I
get compliments on my skin all the time
people will be asking what's your skin
care routine how do you get your skin
and for a lot of fellas talking about
skin care is a little bit awkward
because either we're too ashamed to do
it or it seems a little bit too feminine
but the truth is having rough skin or
having all these little dents everywhere
isn't some that you necessarily want
especially if it's things that you can
easily avoid through very very good
products I recommend going through that
process and that's where tiege Hanley
comes in they got a great system in
place where you can use their products
to achieve your skin care goals I
personally recommend that you start with
the level one system which comes with
all the basics a daily face wash which
gets rid of all the dirt and Grime on
your face then got it two times per week
exfoliating scrub to get rid of all the
dead skin cells and an AM moisturizer
with SPF 20 because we all need to make
sure that our skin is protected from the
Sun and the cool thing about Tia Shanley
is all their boxes come with
instructions in addition to amazing skin
members of th Henley get tons of
benefits like at least 20 off retail
price the ability to pause or cancel at
any time as well as free us shipping and
because thinly sponsoring today's video
if you go to the link in the description
below not only will you get all the
benefits that I just listed but you'll
also get a free gift with your purchase
don't wait rub out that face so you can
actually start looking fresh
trying to find a thing but within our
whole our old thing you can't that
Instagram got deleted even though you
can still find the conversation if
someone's still getting it no after a
while you can it just says Instagram
user huh yeah yeah but you can't find it
how would you find it if it just say
Instagram user you'd have to scroll yeah
and you're not going to go through
General there's hundreds of DMS it's in
general yeah I didn't put in them
I put her in the primaries he going to
General [__] [__] dweeb this girl
is cornishing me uh
um
do I think she's a grifter absolutely
yeah I do I don't think she believes
half the stuff that she says that comes
out of her mouth her friends her family
have already come by and said stuff
against her and she's made up certain
aspects of her life but more importantly
I don't know you just see the switch up
that she's done over the last two years
and it's been fascinating to see the
kind of title she had before contest
she's making to what she's making now I
just don't buy I never did at the end of
the day do I think she's some kind of
race supremacist no I don't I think
she's just somebody who wants to make
money and her capitalistic mindset made
her realize that black men will support
a woman who Echoes what they think
especially if she doesn't look like them
and so they threw money at her truth is
she's a goofy broad who have found a way
into the community and was able to make
a lot of money off you guys and she will
continue because a lot of dudes are more
concerned with getting back at women or
showing them up than they are with
actually getting to the truth of any
situation because if you look at her
she's a giant flaming hypocrite
the thing that she is is the exact thing
that she preaches against she ain't got
no husband she's a career driven woman
who's very very argumentative and isn't
submissive in any type of way how Sheila
wants to tell everyone how to live and
what they should be but she not even an
example of the thing that she talks
about y'all never found that [__] kind
of weird and then all racial issues I
don't even think that she's some kind of
surprise I just think she's ignorant
that's it either since she's ignorant
and when a man came on the platform and
said a bunch of stuff she just didn't
have the word of thought or the ability
to counter anything because she wasn't
well read on it it was a lot of things
that she was agreeing on that you know
was whatever but whatever I just think
she just doesn't know what the [__]
she's talking about which is true for
many of the subjects that she talks on
none of this is surprising so I thought
this was actually kind of boring and
dull
well what do you think it was just very
expensive like it's expected when I saw
that [__] I was like yeah
yeah what the [__] did you expect of
course
so whatever so it's a whatever sandwich
to me and Nick tries to like massage it
sometimes he tries to pretend like he's
not a white supremacist but he is yeah
absolutely is I remember it one time
he's like no no I'm fundamentally I'm
more actually on my Christianity more
than anything else
within this guy in the conversation was
advocating for like a white power
structure he wanted white people in
charge and then I remember I asked him a
question one time I said Nick you get to
choose
you say Christianity is the most
important criteria right he said yeah
I said okay you have to choose between
marrying a black woman who's extremely
Christian or marrying a white woman
who's an atheist what would you choose
the dude went quiet
I'm like bro I thought you said
Christianity is your most important
factor why would you choose
the black one I don't like bro just say
you love whiteness man why are you doing
all this oh Christianity [__] you
know what I mean why are you doing all
this yeah yeah and it's just he is what
he is it's fine when you accept it you
can have that conversation with him you
can push back on his ideas but you need
to actually acknowledge and do some
research and you didn't do that and so
with highly controversial guests does it
mean you can't have them on your
platform no you can you just got to get
ready to actually push back on some of
their ideas that's it so anyways
this one's kind of boring to me but
everybody wanted us to cover it so here
it is but I don't know what you want me
to say I couldn't believe y'all made
this girl popular in the first place but
everyone's allowed to do whatever they
want so you know freedom and speech for
you exactly speech for me you're out to
do some dumb [__] but I'm allowed to
tell you you do absolutely and you're
allowed to tell us we're dumb too yeah
but yeah live your life if you don't
have times people said yo go under
podcast [__] we're not going on that
weirdos podcast
so I go sit there and tell women you're
unreasonable modern women are the
problem oh actually this part was
actually interesting some dude who
worked with her remember the guy I got
no problem with her I got no problem
with that I've been breathing yeah
bro both of you I got smoke for Abba and
preach bro bro please don't mention it
um when you say that don't say we just
say you got smoke because I said that so
this guy came about saying not only she
he you debated a video saying like yo
she takes over 80 to 85 percent of
people's ad Revenue now myself and pal
sat down to have a conversation and she
expressed to me that she wanted to do a
new segment for her show and she said
she would want me within her studio four
days per week I said okay from what time
she said from 10 in the morning till
five o'clock in the evening I said so
working four to five days a week for
seven hours is essentially a day job
what is my guaranteed fee at the end of
the month what is the salary and she
even looks at me and she says we do not
do guarantees and we do not do salary
she does percentages so I said okay cool
well what's the percentage she said
Sarah you're the high end so you will
get 70 30. so I said fine okay let me
listen 70 goes to me and 30 goes to you
now she looked at me and she said no 70
Goes To Me Pearl and 30 goals to me saur
agave and that's when I started
scratching my head I said what's the low
end she said it's 10 to 15 percent which
is like a crazy split even when you
account for business expenses and
everything that's a crazy split that
Pearl who's not even on the camera will
take 85 percent of what the person makes
okay from ad Revenue
no MCM no like marketing agency does
that so that's one two one other thing
that you said he was talking about the
past she ended up filing a bunch of DMC
strikes again to try to get his video
taken of course
it's just fine but when people with no
arguments yeah trying to push back on
things that's one of the that's what
they're going to do DMC strikes strikes
of course she did of course better not
dmc's tracks yeah abusing the system but
anyways let us know what you guys think
about this
um
yeah I got much
full day